معنا من عمان اللي واقف فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء
كل طرف سياده الدقيقه السيطره على اماكن
معينه ولكن هل هناك معلومات معينه يمكن
الوثوق بها من خلال متابعتك
للاسف لا حاولت منذ الصباح ان اضع
الانجازات التي قدمها كل جانب مقابل
الانجازات التي قدمها الجانب الاخر
وتوقفت مليا عند بعض التصريحات حول نفس
الموقع على سبيل المثال
قاعده مروي كان يقول الجيش تم الاستيلاء
عليها كان يقول الدعم تم السيطره عليها ما
يتعلق بالقصر الجمهوري
تتواجد قوات
للدعم السريع في محيطه ولا يوجد اشتباك
يقول تم السيطره عليها القياده العامه في
ظل غياب اي مصدر محايد لا تزال القراءه
ضبابيه ولا يمكن الركود الى هذه التصريحات
التي تصدر من هنا او هناك الا بعد ان يتم
تاكيدها من مراسل للجزيره او غيرها من
ما استغربه يعني انا اذا كنت مسيطر على اي
مكان في وقتها ربما ساصور بهاتفي الجوال
واقول انا في المقر الفلاني الان وكما
تشاهدون هذا هو الوقت هذا هو التاريخ
واشاهد اللواء فايز الدويري على قناه
الجزيره لاؤكد للجميع ان السيطره لماذا لا
يحدث امر من هذا النوع
لانه لا يوجد سيطره فعليه وحقيقيه الان
عندما نتحدث عن مطار مروي المراسلين
تحدثوا عن خروج 110 سيارات ابتعادها
لمسافه ما اصطحاب 27 جندي مصري اصبح هناك
لدينا معلومه يمكن الركون اليها واعتمادها
بينما عندما يقول تم السيطره على المواقع
الفرق في منطقه
دارفور انا لا استطيع ان اتبنى هذا الموقف
ولا يمكن لي ان اخدعه
لمقاربه تحليليه لماذا لانه لم يقدموا لي
اي دليل ملموس على ان هذا التصريح حقيقي
انا هنا لا اوجه انتقادات لو كنت في
مكانهم لو كنت في مكانهم ما هو الدليل
الملموس الذي يمكن ان تقدمه للمتابعين
يا سيده انت اجبت قبل قليل الجميع يملك
الهاتف الذي يستطيع ان يصور ويرسل الجميع
يمتلك الهاتف الان امكانيه التوثيق سهله
جدا لو عدنا الى فتره التسعينات
والثمانينات من القرن الماضي كان علينا ان
ننتظر صور الاقمار الصناعيه
وعلى سبيل المثال ان تقدم للشركه ماكسر
لنا بعض القراءات الحقيقيه الان لا اي
مراسل اي شخص يستطيع ان ينقل الحدث لحظه
بلحظه ونقل حي هذا لم يحدث وبالتالي لا
يمكن لي كمحلل ان اعتمد هذه البيانات اذا
اخذت ببيانات المستشار القانوني لقوات
الدعم السريع انا اقول المعركه شرفت على
الانتهاء لصالح قوات الدعم السريع اذا
اخذت قراءات التي تقدم من الجانب القوات
المسلحه اقول الان نسير في طريق
الان من الامور الملفته ان الدعم السريع
وقت الدعم السريع تقول انها دمرت طائره
اباتشي وهو ما اثار تساؤلات عن نوعيه
الاسلحه او الطائرات العموديه التي
يمتلكها الجيش السوداني وان كان من بينها
طائره الاباتشي
يعني حول هذه النقطه تحديدا حول هذه
النقطه تحديدا حاولت ان اعود الى معظم
المراكز البحثيه والمراكز المعنيه بتسليح
الجيوش وتحديد
مكوناتها من من هذه الاسلحه لم اجد اشاره
حقيقيه مباشره موثوقه ان السودان يمتلك
طائره الافاتشي هناك اشاره من اللواء
اسماعيل مجذوب لواء سوداني قال بان الجيش
السوداني يمتلك لكنه لم يقدم عدد ولم يقدم
تاريخ معين بينما في معظم المواقع الجيش
السوداني يمتلك طيفا واسعا من الطائرات من
الصين من روسيا من امريكا من اسبانيا ولكن
حيث ما يتعلق بالطائرات العموديه تحديدا
لا يوجد اي اشاره انهم يمتلكوا اباتشي او
طائره كوبرا ولكنهم يمتلك الطائره الروسي
ميل سماء 24 وما يطلق عليها صاعده
الدبابات وهذه الطائره استخدمت كثيرا في
دول الشرق الاوسط وخاصه العراق المعلومات
التي استطعت الحصول عليها من بعض المراكز
مراكز الدراسات المعنيه
بتسليح الجيوش في مختلف دول العالم ان
الجيش السوداني يمتلك 73 طائره عموديه
منها 43 طائره
عبوديه مقاتله معظمها طائرات ميل 24 نعم
نعم شكرا شكرا فايزه الدويري من عمان خبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي